hello everyone
thank you for attending the live webinar
understanding
the potential impact of the gut
microbiome on stars kobe 2
research today's speaker is dr husan
shin
product manager in the clinical next
generation sequencing division
at thermo fisher scientific during the
webinar
if you have any questions please use the
chat box
in the presentation window and we will
answer as many questions
as we can after the presentation if we
cannot get to them
we will follow up with you after the
live event
now i would like to introduce our
speaker today dr houston chin
hussein shin focuses on developing and
managing ngf based products
for human health research her most
recent launch
was the ion amplifique microbiome health
research assay
this along with the recent release of
the complete ion reporter microbiome
analysis solution
allows for an optimized microbiome study
esten you may now begin your
presentation
great thank you for the introduction
it's great to be here today
in today's presentation i would like to
discuss the potential impact
of the gut microbiome on science cov2
research
and this is because emerging research
shows
that there may be an association between
the clinical manifestation of steroid
infection and the gut microbiome
and it's been well documented that a
reduction in the diversity of the gum
microbiome
which is known as dysbiosis is
associated
with a number of diseases including
respiratory infections
so one of the big questions surrounding
sars-cov2 infection is
why is there such a big disparity in the
severity of the disease
among individuals and then the ultimate
question is
how can we develop effective treatments
and vaccines to help combat this disease
so as science cov2 continues to impact
billions of lives
across the globe exploring a potential
association between cysco v2
and the gut microbiome is an important
consideration
which may lead to the development of
more effective
intervention strategies in the future
so with that said i'll move on to the
agenda for today's presentation
which will be in three parts so in the
first part
i'll give a little background on the gum
microbiome and how
imbalances in the system can have a
significant consequences for a number of
diseases including infectious disease
and in the second part i'll introduce
potential
implications for the gum microbiome in
the context of sarcobi2 infection
is specifically related to
gut microbiome and long axis gut and
lung axes
and implications for disease severity
and potential
role in vaccine efficacy as well as
emerging
avenues for the future research
finally i'll briefly introduce iron
empty sig microbiome health research kit
which we feel can be a key resource to
facilitate
research into this emerging area of
study
and after the presentation as mentioned
we'll have a few minutes for me to
answer any questions you may have
okay
so let's begin with an introduction to
the gut microbiome
and its emerging impact on human health
and disease
so microbiome is a diverse collection of
microbes that can be found
naturally occurring in different
locations of our body such as
the mouth the skin and the gut and these
microbiomes especially
those in the gut play a major role in
some human diseases
interactions between the gut microbiome
and the human host
are complex and are also bidirectional
microbes are provided with a protective
habitat
and nourishment from the host and these
microbes in turn
are beneficial to the host by helping
regulate various physiological functions
including dietary digestion and also
providing protective immunity
against pathogens
the gum microbiome is also known to
significantly regulate the development
and functioning of the innate
and adaptive immune system
so there is this complex back and forth
going on between the gut microbiome
and the host immune homeostasis
specifically dysbiosis of the gut
microbiome
is associated with various immune
related diseases
such as diabetes and autoimmune diseases
as well as gastrointestinal disorders
such as ibt
and ibs additionally the
microbiome can impact how well people
with cancer respond to
treatments such as ntpdl1 immunotherapy
and this has been shown in several
cancer types including melanoma
lung and kidney cancer more recently
it's been also documented that the gut
microbiome has profound
impact on the host response to
infectious diseases
such as in respiratory infections like
tuberculosis and
pneumonia so there is a growing need for
understanding how the gut microbiome
influences the immune system and this
knowledge that may help
guide the development of therapeutic
interventions for growing number of
important human health conditions
including infectious disease
so how is it that disruption to the
diversity of the gun microbiome
can lead to acute and chronic diseases
well it turns out that changes in the
gut microbiome can have
both local and systemic biological
events
for example some local effects that are
well understood
include metabolizing non-digestible
nutrients
providing protection against gut
infections
helping to maintain intestinal barrier
functions
and also educating the immune system
however it's being increasingly
appreciated that in addition to local
effects
the gut microbiome also has systemic
effects
through the production of
anti-inflammatory metabolites
such as short-chain fatty acids that are
transported around the body
which are products of bacterial
fermentation of non-digestible nutrients
like
fiber in the case of dysbiosis
these important protective effects that
are provided by the gum microbiome
are compromised and this contributes to
the development of immune related
diseases
and another area of
active investigation has been around
cancer
immunotherapy research as i mentioned
earlier
recent evidence has demonstrated that
dysbiosis
associated with how well an individual
with cancer will respond to
immune checkpoint inhibitors
in this situation a healthy immune
system is required for a person to have
a good response to the treatment
and given that dysbiosis can negatively
impact the immune system
it's not surprising that dysbiosis can
impact
how a person will respond to
immunotherapy
so the current working hypothesis is
that a diverse microbiome
results in a diverse immune system that
is better able to understand
cancers or recognize cancers after
immune checkpoint inhibition a diverse
microbiome and distinct microbial
composition signatures are therefore
potential biomarkers for
how well a person is likely to respond
to immunotherapy
so this gives us a sense of how the
microbiome can have a significant impact
on chronic diseases
but the gum microbiome also has a
significant impact
in infectious disease so the traditional
concept has been that an infection
occurs in a linear progression
a pathogen enters the host the pathogen
evades the host defenses colonizing the
host
and resulting in the disease
so the research has been mostly focused
on
understanding the mechanisms by which
estrogen can overcome
host defenses and establish infections
however more recently research has
shifted focus
to host pathogen interactions and how
the indigenous microbiome is an
additional element
that plays a critical role in
determining susceptibility to pathogens
and the outcome of the infection
so for example the microbiome plays a
key role
in colonization resistance as part of
the mucosal
immune system which provides a physical
and chemical barrier in the gut
epithelium
is responsible for secretion of
antimicrobial peptides
and produces targeted antibodies
and short chain fatty acids produced by
certain bacteria
can systematically alter the production
of antimicrobial peptides
and reduce the fitness of pathogens by
inhibiting
their growth alternatively
changes to the microbiome can result in
host
immune changes leading to chronic
low-grade inflammation
which can result in a greater risk for
infection
and this relationship between microbiome
structure
and altered immune response is
exemplified in the lungs
where enrichment of anaerobes such as
privotella
and velonella is associated with an
elevated
inflammatory state leading to increased
infection susceptibility
so it's becoming clear that infectious
diseases should not be considered a
singular microorganism problem
and as research shifts to investigating
the complex dynamics between microbial
communities and the host immune system
will gain a better understanding of how
infectious diseases can be prevented
and how therapeutic approaches can
potentially be adapted or
developed
okay so that gives a brief overview of
how the gut microbiome is known to
impact human health and disease
so now let's consider how this may
relate to sars cov2 research
so we have discussed that the ecosystem
of the gun microbiome can have
can both regulate and be regulated by
invading pathogens including viruses
facilitating an effective immune
response
therefore the question arises around
whether the interaction between
the gum microbiome and sars cov2 may
play a role
in the intensity of the infection and
clinical outcomes
over the next few slides i'd like to
review three potential areas where
the gut microbiome may have an impact on
sarcoid ii research
namely gut lung axis
the gut microbiome and its association
with disease severity
and starts cov2 vaccine development
research
so starting with the gut lung axis
recent research has revealed that there
is a vital crosstalk
between the gut microbiome and the lungs
known as
the gut long axis the gut lung axis
allows for the passage of molecules such
as
endotoxins microbial metabolites
cytokines and hormones through the
bloodstream
connecting the two distant organs
so for example alterations in microbial
species of the gut
and the metabolites that they produce
have been linked to the development of
lung-related
diseases such as asthma and copd
as well as infectious diseases
so for example in people with
tuberculosis
significant shifts in the relative
abundance of short-chain fatty acid
producing bacteria like
rosevaria fecalitarium and eubacterium
have been observed
additionally specific microbial
composition changes have been
linked to influenza virus infections
a protective role for the gut microbiome
during pneumonia has also been
demonstrated
so taking together these observations
suggest
that immune responses at distant mucosal
sites can be
regulated by gut microbiome affecting
outcomes in response to bacterial
and viral infections in the lungs
and interestingly the gut lung axis is
bidirectional
and the integrity of the gut microbiome
could also be disturbed by stars cov2
causing gut dysbiosis in the host as
with other infectious diseases
so these observations point towards the
possible involvement
of the gut lung axis for disease
progression in people with starcov2
infections
so with respect to the gut long axis
some potential connections can be drawn
based on a number of characteristics of
stars coveted infections
so for example sarcobi2 primarily causes
lung infection through
binding of h2 receptors
that are present on alveolar epithelial
cells
and acetyl receptors are reported to be
expressed in intestinal epithelial cells
in the gastrointestinal tract as well
and also intestinal epithelial cells are
known to harbor sars coronavirus
which caused the major sars infection in
2002 and
2003 and stars called v2
rna has also been detected in the stool
of some individuals with cytoskeleton
infection
gastrointestinal symptoms including
diarrhea
are also frequently observed in these
individuals
and recent research indicates that sars
cov2 may also be spread
by fecal oral transmission
also the highest of stars cov2 mortality
and morbidity is in the elderly and in
those with
underlying health problems such as
diabetes
and these groups tend to have less
diverse gut microbiomes
so given these observations further
research into the gi tract
in the context of stars kobe 2 infection
progression
should be considered to gain a better
understanding
of the complexities surrounding this
disease
so now i'm going to discuss the
potential relationship between the gun
microbiome
and the disease severity so
during the initial start cov2 outbreak
in china
early research coming out of the first
affiliated hospital
indicated that bacteria in the gut may
have a significant
impact on the range and the severity of
symptoms associated with sarcoid
infections after profiling the gum
microbiome
of the cytokovich infected individuals
these researchers found
that many of those with more severe
disease exhibited
gut microbiome dysbiosis
specifically there was a decrease in
probiotic organisms including
lactobacillus
and b-fetobacterium and both of these
probiotics are known to have
anti-inflammatory properties
and furthermore these researchers are
suggest
that the use of probiotics may even play
a role
in control of possible secondary
infections
and proliferation of pathogenic
microorganisms
an additional evidence for link between
the gun microbiome and sarcoby ii
comes from a study that reported over 60
percent of individuals with sarcoid
infection displayed gastrointestinal
symptoms
such as diarrhea nausea and vomiting
and this group of subjects also tended
to have
a more serious or critical form of the
disease
based on an analysis of the data the
authors went on to describe
20 proteins associated with disease
severity including
immune factors known to be elevated
during systemic
inflammation they then generated
proteomic risk score
or prs based on these proteins
and using machine learning algorithms
they were able to correlate the prs to
the microbiome
from study subject special samples
demonstrating an association between
microbiome composition and disease
severity
we've taken together these initial
findings
suggest a potential role for the gun
microbiome in the pathogenesis of
cytokine ii infection
finally i'd like to briefly discuss how
the microbiome can potentially
impact vaccine efficacy
surveying efficacy has a number of known
confounding factors such as pre-existing
chronic infections
got associated pathologies use of
immunosuppressive therapies and
antibiotic treatments among others
and over the past decade
various studies have revealed that a
number of these
factors are influenced by the gut
microbiome
so for instance the diversity of the gut
microbiome
plays an important role in the
production of adjuvants
that play key functions in antibody
production
and therefore the potential for
vaccination success against infection
together these observations suggest that
to understand
how our immune systems respond to viral
vaccines and to optimally modulate this
response
we need to study not only the genetics
of the host and the virus in relation to
the vaccine
but also the relationship with the gut
microbiome
and to look at this in a bit more detail
a recent research
demonstrated how gut dysbiosis resulting
from
this the use of antibiotics impacted the
immune response to vaccines
using influenza as an example
but this study showed that a decrease in
microbiome diversity
could be observed up to 180 days after
antibiotic treatment prior to
vaccination
and this dysbiosis led to the
upregulation of inflammation
impaired production of antibodies and
resulted in
an overall dampening of the immune
response
so essentially what's been found is
simple
you need to have healthy immune system
to successfully produce antibodies to
the vaccine
and so you can so you're able to develop
immunity against the virus
and again the diverse and well-balanced
microbiome promotes a healthy
and diverse immune system
okay so to sum up more research
is certainly needed to get a better
understanding
of the association between cyroscov2
infection
and the gut microbiome and the potential
implications of this for optimizing
therapeutic approaches for the disease
as we're all aware there is an urgent
need for effective treatments
based on antivirals and vaccines and
so it's important to explore any
potential
intervention strategies that may exist
and one approach would be by studying
the
gut microbiome profile of individuals
and developing effective dietary or
clinical interventions
to improve gut dysbiosis and thereby
potentially
improving overall immune response in
such
subjects the prebiotics or probiotics
have been
shown to be effective in some studies to
regulate dysbiosis
however there remains insufficient
evidence to support
the blind use of conventional probiotics
as a supplement
so until much more is known about the
pathogenesis of cytokine ii
and its association with the gut
microbiome
scientists suggest that a more targeted
therapeutic approach for
modulation of the gum microbiome is
likely needed
and finally the role of the lung
microbiome
should also be investigated although
technically more
challenging to study insights from
such studies may well add a new
dimension
to the understanding of infectious
diseases
so to conclude in the fight against
infections like coronavirus
a healthy gut microbiome is potentially
a key
factor in maintaining an optimal immune
system
which is especially important given that
both
an over-reactive and under-reactive
immune response can lead to adverse
effects
that could result in clinical
complications
so earlier this year we launched our new
ion mpc microbiome health research kit
we worked with our key research
collaborators to develop
our commensal gut bacterial species
panel
that are associated with immune related
disorders
as an example i want to briefly show you
a pilot study with one of the
researchers
to demonstrate how we can study gut
microbiome
as it relates to disease such as
cytoscopy ii infection
so the data that i'm presenting here is
from a researcher
studying diabetes at a regional research
institute
that is affiliated with a local hospital
so that they have access to
samples from individuals with diabetes
they aim to investigate the gut
microbiome composition in subjects with
different types of diabetes as well as
healthy controls to better understand
the role of the gut microbiome in
diabetes
so in this slide i'm showing an example
data of type 2
diabetes when the authors
compared samples from healthy
individuals to subjects with type 2
diabetes
they saw a clear trend of increased
levels of bacteria
to formicate ratio and
while these these are from the small
sample numbers
the result is consistent with what's
been published in the literature
and at the species level an increased
level of bacteria's vulgaris and
decreased
level of fecalitarian proximity in
subjects with type 2 diabetes were
observed
which is again consistent with the
literature
so finally with high accuracy and
reproducibility that this essay provides
researchers are planning to investigate
the microbiome profile changes
over a time course to study the impact
of clinical or dietary interventions
as well
so one of the key features of this essay
is that
it's a fully validated sample to answer
workflow with an analysis solution also
included
the ion reporter analysis solution for
this essay provides
visualization options for single and
multi-sample analyses
including interactive full taxonomy
classification plot
tech bar plots for relative abundance
heat map and pcoa plots for unsupervised
clustering analysis
and link to chime 2 software
it provides alpha and beta diversity
plots and matrix
and another point that i want to mention
here is that
the solution uses up-to-date and most
widely used
reference databases such as silva
database
so this essay offers two panels one
comprehensive 16s panel
using eight of nine hypervariable
regions
and this allows the global microbiome
composition analysis
for overall picture of the microbiome
and the target species panel for highly
specific
species level identification of 73
key bacterial species known to be
associated with those immune related
diseases
and i want to mention here that the
target species panel
contains a large number of the known
bacterial species with
antiviral or immune modulating
properties as
listed on this slide
so this essay has great uh potential
utility
for studying the association between the
gut microbiome
starts cov2 and our immune system
and we look forward to hearing more
about the research in this area
okay so with that i'll end my
presentation thank you for listening
and now i'll be happy to take any
questions you may have
thank you very much hussain for a very
informative presentation
let's go ahead and take a few questions
from the audience
so your first question here says
can you elaborate a bit more about the
significance
of the fecal transmission route of sars
kobe 2 that you mentioned
yeah sure thank you for the question um
so in addition to transmission via
droplets and closed
contacts that we are aware
fecal oral transmission has also been
shown to be important in some cases
so gastrointestinal connection with
cytoscopic infection that i've
addressed in this presentation and the
fact that the virus has been detected
from
fecal samples all support the fecal oral
roots
in the disease transmission but the
significance of this
is still unclear and so
we need more research on this subject
but the
possibility of the virus transmission
via
sewage water wastewater or contaminated
water
i guess cannot be underestimated
great thank you okay our next question
says
um you said that it is more challenging
to investigate lung
microbiome why is it more challenging
yeah a great question uh so microbiomes
at other sites other than the gut uh
such as lungs received less attention uh
that's because of relatively a low
microbiome biomass compared to gut
microbiome
and also some technical difficulties
so the studies demonstrating the
presence of microorganisms in the lung
change the conventional belief that
lungs are sterile
but still the progress on the lung
specific microbiome
has been slow and that's mostly due to
various sampling
challenges so for example the
respiratory tract
is anatomically much more complex than
the gi tract
and the microbial flow in the lungs can
also be bi-directional with airflow
while it's one directional flow for
gun microbiome and obtaining
equal samples samples is easy and
non-invasive
but sampling lungs for microbial
assessment is prone to contamination and
it's difficult because of
its complicated structure and the proper
sampling technique can be quite invasive
and also limited with limited
nutrition compared to the gut uh there
is higher turnover rate and fewer
microbiota in the lung as i've mentioned
as well so uh it's it's challenging
however if i think it's still a very
valuable
area of research as i addressed in the
presentation
thank you season we have time for just a
couple more questions
now let's go with this one if there is
there a connection
between the severity of cobia 19 do you
see the microbiome being more
central to stratification of people who
are at high risk
yeah oh it's a very good point yes
i think could be possible and it is in
fact
actively being investigated so
it's also been shown in cancer for
example the researchers are finding
microbial signatures associated with
specific cancers
and also responds to therapies like
antibiotic immunotherapy that i
mentioned earlier
so understandably there is interest in
developing a stool based diagnostic
for risk of mortality from sarcoid
infection and also immune supporting
microbiome therapeutics great question
thank you okay and let's go ahead and
take this last question for today
there are reports that antibodies will
only last for a couple of months
and those infected by stars kobe 2.
is there any evidence that the gut
microbiome may play a role here
oh that's also a great question
while i can't really comment on the
specifics of this topic
we have been monitoring all the
publications
that pertains to the key areas of
research
and and yes there have been recent
studies
or preprints suggesting that antibodies
do
peak and then decline after a couple of
months
but clearly more work is needed to fully
understand
the longevity of the immune response to
the virus
and also if or how
the microbiome plays a role there
i'll also mention that there is still a
wealth of information
that is out there and as a quick plug
you can always read more about the
latest research on farm official website
which is called behind the behind the
bench blog
thank you again hison do you have any
final comments for our audience before
we go today yeah i just want to say
thank you
uh to everyone for attending this
webinar on a very interesting topic
and i look forward to hearing more
questions from you
thank you
thank you and i'd also like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions any
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
we would like to thank you sun for her
time today and for her important
research
we would also like to thank labyrus and
our sponsor thermo fisher scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
you can view this webinar on demand
labbers will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
that's all for now until next time
goodbye